sin sorpresas El Banco Central europeo
vuelve a subir los tipos de interés y lo
hace de nuevo con una subida histórica
de 75 puntos básicos El Banco Central
europeo con esta medida por lo tanto
sitúa la tasa de interés en el 2% en la
eurozona esta decisión se toma a pesar
de las amenazas de una posible recesión
en la zona Euro siguiendo así con su
política de tipos de los últimos meses
la persistente inflación que ahora mismo
se encuentra cercana al 10% en la zona
Euro ha llevado a la institución a tomar
esta decisión es la tercera vez que el
eurobanco decide subir los tipos en los
últimos meses con esta medida el
eurobanco lo que intenta es reducir la
demanda e intentar frenar lo máximo
posible la inflación aún así la misma
institución de hecho la presidenta del
eurobanco cristín lagart admite que la
inflación va a seguir alta y de hecho no
mayores subidas de tipos en los próximos
meses el objetivo del Banco Central
europeo es tener una inflación cercana
al 2% pero ahora mismo la meta está muy
lejos de conseguirse sobre todo porque
esta inflación se ha visto muy influida
a causa de Los Altos precios de la
energía y también por los problemas en
la cadena de suministro